général puis je donner mon avis josé
côte
cette opération risque de faire de
nombreuses victimes
doit-on poursuivre
[Musique]
c'est la plus risquée les opérations
militaires que j'ai pu voir jusqu'à
présent
pourquoi se focaliser sur la plage d'une
seule le 15 septembre à minuit précise
je débarquerai à winston
j'ai besoin qu'on ouvre la voie
[Musique]
entré en contact avec le bureau de
liaison des chalets allumé le phare de
palmetto et mener notre flotte au rivage
[Musique]
pourquoi vous êtes vous porter
volontaire pour cette opération
je voulais protéger ma mère
[Musique]
est ce que vous proposez siegfried
je suis douglas macarthur je gagne la
guerre lancée l'opération chrome ait
[Musique]
allez